when you to do your pics and your list
and stuff I love it when you're just
rattled back to the heads wagon here
here we go come on baby oh my gosh I've
gotten cold you need to regroup you need
to collect yourself you know I love my
son but damn son you're embarrassing you
know it's always good to have an
unbiased view to tell us how we're doing
on these but when there's a guy who
actually has reason to side with his son
and he's saying you son you're on the
ropes you're getting punched through I
like it you don't know my father he
would never show my ass to his son he
would rather you win so he could get on
me everyday and do what he did so trust
me he said he'll be sitting here
watching this or maybe the rerun
depending on when he gets up you know
and his privileged life right now but he
will be watching this at some point
today and he'll be rooting for you to
win this trap I had a bad week last week
I'll admit that
you want a few of those draft I think it
was the first time you want to draft in
a long time but you beat me last week
not a few all of them I want a hell of a
streak and you know the rigged coin toss
has been going against you recently
let's see if you can pull it off today
this will be a good sign as to whether
or not you have any chance of winning
the draft tails tails tails tails yes he
got big boy yeah this is it is not easy
you know I mean best scrambling
quarterbacks okay I'm gonna go with
Russell Wilson as my number one pick
okay it's just a proven commodity I've
seen Russell Wilson just do it too much
over the last few years just absolutely
pull magic you know in big situations
fourth quarter whatever it may be
Russell Wilson's one of the greatest
scrambling quarterbacks in the history
of football as far as making magic
happen not only when he just tucks the
ball down and decide he wants to run I'm
more in I'm more the big place happen
when he's dancing around behind the the
line of scrimmage makes people miss you
know spins out the back door like he
does sometimes and then you know find
something happen in 30 40 yards down the
field whatever it is that's where
so Wilson is his absolute dangerous are
at his most dangerous so yeah I'm gonna
go with Russell Wilson is the number one
scrambler in football right now still
yep
now scrambler can be a very know it can
be very big right because scramble
implies that you intend to pass and
everything falls apart and then you take
off and run Yeah right that's not
designed run quarterback that scrambling
quarterback who can make something out
enough right do you agree on that I do
agree on that a hundred percent yes I
think there was other quarterbacks that
I could have picked that's it would have
been better running quarterbacks where I
said okay but the draft was entitled
scrambling and to me that brings another
group of quarterbacks into this
conversation it's not necessarily about
their ability to tuck the ball down and
just run for yards down the field it's
about scrambling and making plays that
way given that definition I'm gonna
surprise you here and I'm gonna leave
some names on the board and I don't care
but if we are going to focus on the true
scrambler the guy who is setting up the
pass yeah and he doesn't have anything
and he sees a lane and off he goes I'm
going Mitchell true Biscay ok ok true
true Biscay is as dangerous or more
dangerous than that because you don't
expect him to do it he ran circles
around the Vikings on that Sunday night
game remember the one where Kirk Cousins
said the reason they flex this game
isn't because of them it's because uh
Sanders kicked the crap out of it right
true Biscay sneaky great scrambling
ability there he is setting up the pass
where you're watching on TV and off he
goes and you are not gonna get him until
look at that yes stop and start and go
and he's going and he's looking I get
inside the 5-yard line look at it unless
you're watching on radio so Mitchell
true Biscay under that definition not
gonna be a popular pick because you have
to think about it and you have to
understand the term scrambling
I think mr. drew Biscay actually been in
better selection than Russell Wilson cuz
I'd say plenty his runs are designed not
many of true Biscay zone well that's not
right you're wrong we saw plenty of
highlights there that weren't designed
runs and too risky hey Mike I'm not mad
at you at all for that pick this is one
of the best running quarterbacks in
football another guy that for some
reason because people just want to like
bag on them all the time
divin didn't give him credit for some of
the runs he made last year in big
situations which were like you know
game-changing Tyco runs like we
just saw with the New England Patriots
game the only thing I'll argue and push
back with you with Mitchel job risky to
where I think maybe some other
scramblers are better than him
is he doesn't always scramble to throw
when he does run it's special but he
doesn't scramble and try to go okay I've
danced around and behind the line of
scrimmage for you know three or four
people and then make a laser down the
field that's where I'm gonna push back
just because I want to make sure I win
this draft okay and I'm gonna win this
you're not you're not buying time like
Ben Roethlisberger that's not scrambling
scrambling is know that basically the
greatest scrambling heart Tarkenton is
really like talking to know Brandt Arkin
fans brother Frank was a horrible
quarterback Fran was a very good quarter
but he's known for scrambling right and
he was scrambling he wasn't running ever
he just scrambled and ran around to
throw the ball and that's why I go with
pic number two with another phenomenal
scrambler and Patrick mahomes and he
never really runs the ball but I'm gonna
go with him here because Patrick mahomes
is the ultimate oh crap he broke out of
the pocket who knows what the hell is
gonna happen in defensive corners
coordinators and head coaches have seven
heart attacks once he breaks to his
right I mean we've seen some of the
plays he can make so yeah I'm gonna go
with it because once we're talking about
scrambling again but yeah okay Patrick
Munoz up and it might not be my top pick
for a guy where I go oh he's gonna tuck
it and run for 15 or 20 yards scrambling
that way but if you want to talk about
making people miss behind the line of
scrimmage and extending a play and
making game-changing throws off of his
scrambling to keep people alive that's
where I go Patrick mahomes he's already
in the conversation for one of the
greats ever he already is I mean we saw
things last year and plays outside the
pocket where I mean hey we're watching
the Chargers game that they had where
Phillip Rivers was on the sidelines
going damn I can't do that remember he
was doing that on the sidelines like
that's amazing and then here's the
Ravens gets a low bar no it's a low ball
it is a low bar but still nonetheless I
don't think he would say that unless he
was just like oh my gosh this guy is
unbelievable and that's unbelievable is
I'm kicking your butt today for your
going down remember we did the top five
Patrick mahomes throws out in the snow
at Arrowhead Stadium and one of mine was
the play against San Francisco and I I
invoked Fran Tarkenton in that moment
you did rolling left and rolling right
and then through the missile to the
endzone drives Connolly so all right
this is interesting this is top this is
a good draft like this yeah this one
yeah I had an idea now I'm going another
way with it you know if we're gonna if
you're gonna pick Kyler Murray at number
24 among all quarterbacks based on a
projection largely driven by his
mobility yeah I'm gonna go ahead and
roll the dice on Kyler Murray column er
I went yeah that's why he was the number
one overall pick in the draft it wasn't
his size right and I know he's got a
great arm but the mobility is the thing
that is going to give defensive
coordinators heartburn all year long his
ability to take off with the ball
whether it is buying time behind the
line of scrimmage straddling that way or
taking off with the football when
there's nothing down the field open and
he sees 20 30 yards of green that he can
get to before anyone else can get to him
so I'll go with the first overall pick
in the draft pick first overall because
of those legs in large part so I'll go
color Murr I'm not I'm not gonna be mad
at you there Mike I mean come on this
guy's like special as we talked about
when we broke him down in the first hour
I mean this is the most gifted runner to
come in football since Michael Vick and
I cannot believe I'm saying that the
year after Lamar Jackson because I was
absolutely in love with market Lamar
Jackson's ability to run the ball coming
out of Louisville but this was a
different level because not only is it
the speed straightaway but to what
you're saying I mean we see Barry
Sanders Darren Sproles type of moves
with this guy where he can break ankles
in space some guys trying to tackle him
so yeah he was coming up for me so
that's a good good job by you picking
them there okay this is where I don't
know what to do here there's you know
what's amazing is you start to break
down quarterbacks in right now and you
start to realize wow mobility is kind of
important in 2019 so many of them can
actually run and I'm going to go with my
third and final pick Oh Aaron Rodgers
[Music]
wants you once you twisted the
definition are you how are you defining
it this way and not taking Aaron Raj and
there you go and there you go and that's
how I put the nail in the coffin
everybody at home this one's over when
you get Wilson the Holmes and Rogers
it's over it's an annihilation he's done
Aaron Rodgers he is in Fran Tarkenton
Ville or Frank tarkington whoever you
want to talk about there Fran Tarkenton
but yeah Fran Tarkenton I'll get that
right eventually today but will
certainly go down is one of the greatest
scramblers extending of plays of all
time I mean gosh I feel like so many of
his highlights you know are just him
dancing around making magic happen
nobody's opened let me pump fake here
okay let me dance around in the pocket
like hot potatoes and you know make
another another unbelievable throw I
mean that's all we've seen Aaron Rodgers
do the last four or five years that's
been my problem is we have to rely on
him making these magical moments all the
time and there's nothing easy so Rodgers
will go down as one of the all-time you
know play extenders pointing around as
you're seeing here on TV makes people
miss and certainly on the move or
throwing you know untraditional
deliveries nobody's been better than
Aaron Rodgers you know it's funny you
keep mentioning Fran Tarkenton when I
was a kid I was a huge Fran targeted fan
and if someone mispronounced his name on
TV if someone said Tarkington I would
get pissed like throw your shoe at the
TV I mean I would get so mad if someone
said talking cause he better stop back
scrambling who do you think like yes
yeah I mean he could run circles around
anyone I mean there's some highlights of
him left and right and back and go back
30 yards and finally throwing the ball
and so because I cuz there's a lot that
are still out there and I don't know who
to pick next but I think that it's only
fair a guy who got overlooked last year
for some reason even though he's too
one its division and he proved to us as
a rookie he's got that very uncanny
sense of how to buy time and work his
body in relation to the defenders who
were going after him even though he
doesn't have blazing speed
he gets the most out of what he has and
that's deshaun Watson the Texans
quarterback yeah I'm a little surprised
you hadn't picked him sooner because I'd
say he's a better scrambler than Patrick
mahomes Patrick Holmes a better thrower
right I think deshaun Watson is a better
scrambler than Patrick mahomes
so you left him on the board until the
very end I'll gladly take you no yeah
yeah it's a good pick yeah he is you
know what Mike I'm not gonna argue with
you there he is a better scrambler than
mahomes I don't know if he's not as good
as making the big time throw off of his
scrambling as well as this little
phenomenal what's that what's that wait
is the draft best players who make big
time throws off of scrambling or is it
best scrambles you've just conceded it
you're counting your money and you're
conceding it so just go ahead and go see
it I'm not conceited just did he might
he was gonna call you f he's got great
movement you know he's he faster than
the home certainly we can play back the
tape he's a better scrambler yeah the
draft is who are the best scrambler
you've already you've already you a
better natural water sorry your hand off
so when since when did whatever I say
get held true all the way through now
but he is phenomenal and I'm a huge
deshaun Watson VIN you and I both are I
know that just please stop getting hit
so hard to Shaun Watson that's our only
our only wish for you let's take a break
before we do though Chris's picks
Russell Wilson Pat from Holmes Aaron
Rodgers I've got Mitchell true Biscay
caller Murray deshaun Watson the best
scrambling quarterbacks in the NFL
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports